me
4を
[拍手]
goocar
ムード分
今
[音楽]
フープん
20分
[音楽]
本
おっ
4日
[音楽]
プー
ブーブー
[音楽]
車
フープん
フープ
[音楽]
ムード
プー
ん
フープぶー
本ん
[音楽]
ん
ブーブー
[音楽]
車
プー
ムーディん
voodoo
car
[音楽]
フープ
wh
gooプー
プーん
ブーム
[音楽]
ん
プー
[音楽]
プーん
ムード
ブームん
[拍手]
ありがとうございますハンドパン奏者の主
と申しますみなさんよろしくお願い致し
ます
[拍手]
今回のて rex kobe 1人目の
東山者として登場させていただきました
皆さんどうぞ
あの硬くならずに
どうぞ温かい目で見守ってくださいね
ハイエット僕が今この演奏している楽器は
ハンドパンっていう楽器なんですけど
ハンドパンっていう楽器今日見るまでに
もうすでに知ってだよーっていう人って
どれくらいいますか
えっ
結構いるのはほんまですかめっちゃ嬉しい
ありがとうございますあのハンドパンはね
今見てもらったように手でたたくでて連れ
で来ている楽器なのでハンドパンっていう
名称なんですけど2001年頃にスイスの
メーカーによって新たに発明されたすごく
新しい楽器になりますちょうどこのハンド
パンをひっくりないしたような形のドラム
缶をへっ来ましたトリニダードとはこれ
生まれたスティールパンっていう
打楽器があるんですけどハンドパンと
スティールパンはまあ似てるから勘違いさ
れることも結構多いんですけどなんか親子
みたいな関係だけど全然楽器としては別物
なのでハンドパンっていうのをぜひこの
機会に覚えていてください
逆に今の僕の説明を聞いてあ正直
スティールパンのことだと思ってたわって
いう人でございますかあーあーりがとうへ
の正直にすみませんありがとうございます
そうなんですよスティールパンでしょう
って言われること結構あるんですけどね
ハンドパンっていう楽器なのでぜひ覚えて
あげてください
はいえっと遅くなりましたが今回この回遊
をテーマに開催されたテレックス頭に呼ん
でいただいて本当にありがとうございます
先ほどの話の中でもあったんですけど
海遊なんかこう
3スイートが感じ海水とか協会のあっち側
とかこっちがはを
生活に応じて行ったり来たりするような
そういう動く様を表すこの言葉が今回の
テーマだっていう風に聞いたときになんか
すごくハンドパンにぴったりなテーマだ
なぁと思いました
あの
ハンドパンて今見てもらっているように
この
凹みのそれぞれの凹みの部分と真ん中の
出っ張りの部分これが基本的に音が鳴る
場所なんですねもう今見てもらっている
ように
こんだけなんですよ
ピアノとかギターと比べると松任的に持っ
ている音の数が少ないこのハンドパンって
いう楽器の大きな特徴は
あの1台ごとにスケール
音階が決まっているので誰でも簡単に即興
演奏ができるっていうところなんですね
即興演奏っていうとみなさんあんまりこう
ライブとかに言っても耳にする機会多く
ないかもしれないですがどんなイメージが
ありますかねなんかこう
音楽的にすごく難しいことをしてるとか逆
にめちゃくちゃ適当にやってるだけなん
じゃないのとか何かそういう風に思う方も
いるかもしれないです僕にとっての即興
演奏っていうのはなぁこの会場の空気感と
か人の雰囲気とか逆にその時自分が思っ
てる事とかを瞬間的にこう感じ取って音へ
と変換していくっていうことが僕にとって
の即興演奏です
これは
なんか本当に会うっていう言葉でも
言い換えることができるなぁと思いました
例えば
今日の会場の雰囲気はどうですか
あったかいですか冷たいですか
あてないんだよね暖かいですよねあ高い
ですよねでなんかあの
今日ここに来ることを選んだ皆さん
一人一人はどんな思いで今日ここまできて
いま
どんな気持ちでそこに座られているのかと
か
僕も僕ねー
ここから数秒後に演奏しながら自分が何を
思うのかとかそういう境界の彼方川や
こちら側で別にここにいながら全然違う
ところのことを考えてもいいしそういう
ふうに自由に遊ぶようにいろんなところを
いったりきたりするっていう即興演奏って
いう名前の回遊を今から皆さんと一緒に
体験できればと思います宜しくお願いし
ます
[拍手]
me4
[音楽]
持った
ん
[音楽]
わ
voodoo
par ん
おっ
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
おおお
cargoo
おっ
goo
ブーブー品
持っ
た
[音楽]
goo
dare
おっ
プー
me4
分
goo
んはん
ププン
ムード
[音楽]
プーペん
おっ
[音楽]
ぶー
む
ファンっ
フープ
[音楽]
ん
プー
プーん
4分
おっ
6分
goo4
goo
ん
[音楽]
とっ
ん
おっ
よっ
20分
4分
ブーフ
おっ
[音楽]
ん
わ
プープー音
ん
ムードプー
[音楽]
プー
おっ
mood ん
[音楽]
voodoo
フープ
ウーロン
4分
par
[音楽]
おっ
ん
[音楽]
おっ
goo
ありがとうございましたん
&パンポルシェの集でしたありがとう
ございます